plus important encore, je voulais faire un
film sur la vie,
pas seulement sur le fait d'être dans la vie,
mais
sur le bien-vivre,
bien sûr, l'expérience est très
intéressante car nous pouvons le reconnaître, nous
savons ce que deux verres de vin nous font
et nous savons que c'est normalement  très beau
sept est une chose différente
mais deux c'est quelque chose et nous nous en souvenons quand nous
étions enfants comme amoureux quand nous avions 17 ans nous nous en souvenons
quand nous avons rencontré notre femme ou notre mari
mais il y avait quelque chose de plus que
cela dans l'histoire il y avait il y avait  une
étreinte de la vie il y avait vous savez
oser
vivre votre vie et ne pas laisser votre vie
s'arrêter parce que vous n'aurez jamais une
autre chance
c'est maintenant je pense que c'est un
film très optimiste
nous sommes des amis proches avec des tapis dans ce
cas
je voulais faire je voulais faire un
portrait très très nu
d'un être humain et je voulais le faire
voyager d'être
[Musique]
presque un mort-vivant et le faire
vivre
j'ai toujours été un très grand  fan de ça
je suis un grand fan de buster keaton
depuis que je suis tout petit j'adorais
regarder chaplin
mais j'étais amoureux de regarder buster keaton
et je n'ai jamais su pourquoi
mais je pense peut-être parce qu'il avait la
capacité de
dire beaucoup de choses  et ce n'était jamais
spécifiquement
une chose qu'il a dit c'était tout ce que je
voulais qu'il dise
euh alors euh mais je ne le suis pas je ne
prétends pas que je suis cassé je dis juste que
j'ai toujours été amoureux de ça
et  thomas est un réalisateur qui aime aussi le fait qu'il
trouve cela fascinant mais il est
très amoureux de
vous savez le gros plan où il se passe beaucoup de
choses et vous fermez
tout et vous entrez dans
la tête d'une personne
et de tous  d'un coup vous voyez qu'il
n'est pas un homme heureux
et ça sort de nulle part et et et
quand vous savez que c'est son plan alors
vous pouvez aussi en quelque sorte trouver vos petits
outils
pour l'aider à l'écran le
silence donne
un sens  de présence tu sens le temps
flotter avec le silence il y a beaucoup de
bla bla bla
bla et de joker et puis il y a la
pureté
et ces petits étangs de silence
avec des fous
on mentirait si on disait qu'on n'a pas
eu euh d'
expérience qu'on a tous  que comme accès
donc on sait ce que c'est et même si
on n'a pas accès quand on est un peu
ivre
on fait de notre mieux pour ne pas
paraître ivre
tu sais donc ça rend les mouvements un
peu plus lents un peu plus précis
mais  il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas, mais nous avons
bien sûr dû aller au-delà de cela, nous
devions aller au niveau charlie chaplin
et devenir
ivre fou parfois c'était un peu
risqué parce que cela peut aller
terriblement mal, mais ensuite nous avons juste regardé
des vidéos youtube de russie et
c'était comme si c'était insensé, vous savez, alors
nous essayons de copier une partie de cela.
l'humour des personnages vous ouvre les portes et l'
alcool c'est aussi beaucoup de liens c'est une question d'
unité
je ne sais pas combien de couples vous connaissez
qui se sont trouvés
sobres je ne connais personne
euh donc l'humour l'unité
fait partie du même jeu de balle je suppose